qué tal bienvenido de regreso en este
vídeo lo que quiero hacer son algunos
ejemplos de cómo encontrar la anti
derivada o bien la integral indefinida
de una expresión polinomio con un poco
de suerte te voy a convencer que esto no
es tan difícil de hacer entonces vamos a
empezar supongamos que queremos
encontrar la integral indefinida por
supuesto puedes buscar en internet de
este símbolo verdad y vas a encontrar un
dibujo mucho más bonito pero bueno
supongamos que quieres encontrar la
integral indefinida le voy a poner una
expresión grande a ver voy a poner la
integral indefinida de de 3x elevado a
la menos 5 menos 7 x elevado a la 3
+ 3 así nada más menos
x elevado a la 9 entonces tal vez ya te
está intimidando esta expresión pero si
viste el vídeo anterior que es la
introducción a las integrales
indefinidas a lo mejor te diste cuenta
que aunque integrar suena como algo muy
sofisticado en matemáticas en realidad
no es tan sofisticado o bueno al menos
no es tan difícil lo único de lo cual
tenemos que darnos cuenta ahorita es que
así como la derivada de un polinomio es
la suma de las derivadas de cada término
asimismo cuando integramos hacemos lo
mismo es decir cuando queremos integrar
una expresión polinomiales simplemente
tenemos que integrar cada uno de los
sumandos y al final sumar todo entonces
pues vamos a encontrar la integral de
cada uno de estos términos para
encontrar la respuesta vamos a ver esto
es igual a haber 3x a la menos 5 lo que
hay que hacer es tomar el exponente
sumar 1 al exponente entonces
obtendríamos x a la menos 4 x a la menos
4 y ahora tenemos que multiplicar el
coeficiente por 1 entre el nuevo
exponente
entonces uno entre el nuevo exponente es
menos un cuarto y eso lo multiplicamos
por el coeficiente nos queda menos tres
cuartos sale ya acabamos con este primer
término para el segundo de aquí tenemos
x al cubo integrando x al cubo hay que
elevar el exponente en uno entonces nos
queda x a la 4 y ahora tenemos que
multiplicar el coeficiente simplemente
podemos dejar el menos pensar el 7 que
está aquí como menos 7 entonces
multiplicamos menos 7 por un cuarto como
el nuevo exponente es 4 entonces hay que
multiplicar un cuarto por menos 7 nos
queda menos 7 entre 4 o sea menos 7
cuartos ahora vamos con el tercer
término este de aquí es más interesante
3 simplemente tres cómo le hacemos para
manejar este 3 pues este 13 es lo mismo
que 3 por equis a la 0 porque porque x a
la 0 es simplemente 1 y así es como
deberíamos de verlo
esto lo que nos hace ver es que la regla
es muy consistente entonces cuál es la
integral de 3 si lo vemos como 3x a la 0
lo que hay que hacer es que aumentar el
exponente en uno entonces nos queda x a
la 1 lo voy a poner aquí voy a poner
simplemente x sale para no poner
demasiados exponentes y hay que
multiplicar el coeficiente anterior este
3 hay que multiplicarlo por 1 entre el
nuevo exponente como el nuevo exponente
es uno entonces el inverso de uno es uno
entonces nos queda simplemente más tres
porque uno entre uno es uno entre uno es
uno entonces simplemente nos quedan tres
ahora finalmente para este término creo
que ya más o menos le vas agarrando la
onda verdad hay que aumentarle en uno al
exponente nos queda x a la 10 y luego
hay que multiplicar el coeficiente que
ahorita es un 1 lo voy a poner por aquí
hay que multiplicar ese coeficiente por
1 entre el nuevo exponente el nuevo
exponente es 10 entonces es menos un
décimo
sale a esta ya logramos este ejemplo no
fue tan difícil
ayer espérame tantito todavía tenemos
que agregar algo más siempre se me
olvida que hay que agregar un más esto
es porque siempre que derivamos
cualquier constante nos queda 0 entonces
esta constante puede ser lo que sea
puede ser un 10 o un millón o un -23
cualquier constante ahora para verificar
si realmente hicimos bien nuestra
integral vamos a derivar para ver si
obtenemos la expresión original entonces
con un poco de suerte hicimos todas las
cuentas correctamente si alguna vez se
te acaban los problemas de práctica
porque te acabas de todos los del libro
de mate inventaste problemas eso es lo
que yo hago bueno
de hecho de hecho lo hago aunque no esté
haciendo vídeos lo hago así por pura
diversión jeje pero bueno a ver la
derivada de esta cosa de aquí nos queda
menos 4 x menos tres cuartos es 3x hay
que elevarlo al exponente restándole 1
es decir hay que elevarlo x a la menos 5
luego menos siete cuartos x 4 es menos 7
x x a la 4 menos 14 - 13 entonces nos
queda x al cubo te prometo que no estoy
viendo aquí arriba ella lo mejor dice ay
éste sale está nada más copiando lo de
arriba pero no no lo estoy haciendo todo
todo todo derivando hay que derivar
ahora 3 x la deriva de 3x simplemente es
13 eso ya me lo sea así porque practicar
un montón pero podemos pensarlo como un
x a la 1 entonces uno por 3 3 x x a la 0
ahora vámonos para acá 10 x menos un
décimo nos queda menos 1 y hay que
multiplicarlo por x a la 10 menos uno o
sea x a la 9 y luego hay que sumarle hay
que sumarle la derivada de esta
constante la derivada de cualquier
constante cero
verdad podemos pensar este se como un c
se x x a la cero entonces el cero cuando
derivamos x a la cero el cero baja cero
por cero a cero no nos queda x a la
menos uno y luego cómo le hacemos pues
la verdad nos queda cero pero bueno voy
a dejar de mirar por la tangente vamos a
simplificar nos queda 13 quizá la menos
5 menos 7 x al cubo 3 - x a la 9 y
fíjense que esta es justo la expresión
original creo que tenemos tiempo para un
ejemplo más pero que vas viendo la idea
y como ves es algo muy fácil es una de
las cosas más sencillas que podemos
hacer en las presentaciones siguientes
les voy a contar un poco más de para qué
sirve la anti derivada y cómo lo podemos
hacer para usarlo en integrales
definidas y podemos hacer ejercicios de
encontrar áreas trabajo de la curva y
encontrar volúmenes de sólidos de
revolución pero bueno ahorita no te
quiero confundir demasiado vamos a hacer
un ejemplo más vamos a hacer un ejemplo
más
este vamos a encontrar la integral de
menos menos un medio de x pues vamos a
ponerle x a la menos 3 y a eso le
sumamos 7 x a la quinta baja entonces
queremos encontrar la integral de esto
con respecto a x entonces qué hacemos
vamos a empezar con el primer término
entonces elevamos el exponente en uno
entonces nos queda x a la menos 2 verdad
menos tres más uno de los tres más uno
nos quedan dos menos dos entonces hay
que multiplicar por uno entre el nuevo
exponente
entonces vamos a ver nos queda menos un
medio ahora lo que hay que el
coeficiente hay que multiplicarlo déjame
cambiar de color
voy a ponerle aquí menos -2 y voy a
indicar aquí que estoy multiplicando por
menos un medio verdad es uno entre el
nuevo exponente y luego vamos a regresar
al morado entonces el segundo término
nos queda x a la a la 6 porque 6 porque
es 5 16 y hay que multiplicar el
coeficiente anterior por 1 entre el
nuevo exponente entonces nos queda uno
entre 6 voy a pintar con amarillo el
exponente entonces vamos a simplificar
la respuesta menos un medio por un menos
un medio nos queda un cuarto luego hay
que poner un equis a la menos 2 ya eso
hay que sumarle aquí otra vez en olvido
la constante como puedes ver esto de
aquí es donde siempre pierdo puntos en
los exámenes porque se me olvida poner
el margen pero bueno es un cuarto de x a
la menos 2
7 sextos de x a la 6 más la constante a
esta bueno si queremos derivar para
verificar en menos dos por un cuarto es
menos dos cuartos que es menos un medio
hay que hacer x a la menos tres porque
restamos uno al exponente luego seis por
7-6 sextos de 7x a la quinta y cuando
derivamos la constante nos queda cero y
regresamos a la expresión original ahora
con un poco de suerte hábitat ya eres
muy bueno derivando expresiones
polinomiales pero con esto vas a empezar
a agarrar práctica para integrarlas
ahora recuerda que siempre es súper
importante es súper importante esto de
agregar el mazo y hay que entender por
qué hay que poner esto siempre cuando
derivamos las constantes eliminas
entonces cuando integramos no sabemos si
la expresión original tenía o no tenía
una constante o si la tenía cuál era
espero que esto te haya confundido un
poco para que pienses un rato y nos
vemos en la siguiente para ver cómo
invertir la regla de la cadena